like they use the students easily  another week so it's just outrageous  James but this is actually just like  soft shell and like slightly less soft  this probably works Jesus in a natural  binding agent what more would you want a  big loaf of Taco Bell taste I wish there  were a lot more of the red sauce good I  like this sauce  it's  okay like weirdly spicy so wrong so hey  it's like the Mexican equivalent of  fettuccine alfredo there's a little  surprise in it little tortilla chips I  confetti too much potato I think it's  like kind of starchy like I just kind of  like Ortega like taco meat you know what  it doesn't taste bad though I kind of  like it well whatever is in there it's  really good meat i gosh but yeah this is  actually pretty delicious I have the  whole thing I mean it's not that great  but I keep eating it